politically in the United States we are
split down the middle and our last two
elections have been virtual ties which
had the Democrats not been so gracious
as to concede might not have ended
happily at all I think the United States
is really much more potentially
politically unstable than anyone
realizes the notion that the Supreme
Court is going to resolve these problems
is I think a naive notion the political
figures do not have to accept a Supreme
Court decision that was a decision that
the Democrats made algoa made that
decision didn't have to be done so I
think that our system is much more
politically unstable than it looks on
the surface
you